uh now tonight early voting is now
underway ahead of next Tuesday's Georgia
runoff coming up we'll bring you the
very latest from this critical election
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich will get his take on a plus
stunning new scenes out of China look at
that protesters now taking to the
streets against the country's oppressive
Communist dictatorship risking life and
limb some demonstrators by the way
echoing Patrick Henry Give me liberty or
give me death people are bravely calling
for president XI to be removed from
Power Joe Biden of course missing in
action nowhere to be found not standing
up for the freedom fighters in China now
the self-proclaimed defender of
democracy I guess he can't be bothered
away in now for months we have seen a
similar level of moral cowardice from
Biden when it came to Iran the Iranians
have been protesting we have the video
for months after one woman was murdered
for not properly wearing her head scarf
but Joe Biden Champion great champion of
women's rights doesn't seem to carry
even the Cowardly U.N they're speaking
out against the muellers but not Joe
Biden meanwhile in Eastern Europe the
administration is now supplying Ukraine
with weapons and ammunition but
President Biden rarely speaks out in
support of the anti-war movement that is
actually growing inside of Vladimir
Putin's Russia and tonight we actually
have a moment in history where the new
axis of Evil China Russia Iran are all
facing serious crises from within and
yet Biden eerily silent there is no tear
down this fall moment from Joe Biden
there are no powerful speeches about
liberty and justice abroad and freedom
not even a kind word here or there for
those that are risking their lives in
the name of Liberty and why is that well
for starters Joe Biden wants something
from each one of these tyrannical
governments and that means he's weak and
that means he's allowed himself and our
country to be unnecessarily compromised
because of his mysterious reluctant and
resistance to getting our own energy
here domestically and by the way we have
trade deals when he wanted the Iranian
nuclear pack why so what we're going to
make the most in Iran Rich again you
know it's also perfectly you know you
know normal I guess to wonder if Biden's
family Syndicate and their Shady
international business deals are playing
a role but make no mistake when Joe
Biden wants something his deeply held
principles his morals they go right out
the window because he wants accused
remember the Saudi Arabian Crown Prince
MBS himself of murdering journalist
Jamal khashoggi and vowed to treat the
kingdom like a pariah Nation but then
gas prices went up and Biden traveled
all the way to Saudi Arabia got on his
hands and knees to beg mbfs to pump more
oil and by the way they said no and then
even worse Biden asked the judge to
Grant the Saudi Crown Prince legal
immunity not only did they deny his
request to increase output they
decreased output and then they told the
American people the truth Joe asked them
to withhold that announcement until
after the midterm election oh that'd be
a quitting a pro and a quo now that he's
given MBS immunity well lo and behold
Saudi Arabia they're now considering to
increase Opex oil production but it's
not a quid pro quo if you're a Democrat
or Joe Biden and by the way it's not
only Saudi Arabia breaking this weekend
Biden lifted sanctions on Venezuela and
granted energy Giants Chevron permission
to restart oil production inside the
murdering dictator Thug maduro's
socialist hellhole now whether it's
Russia China Iran Saudi Arabia OPEC or
Venezuela Joe wants deals with America's
enemies brutal dictatorships that murder
opponents shun all human rights all
decency in the Civilized world and by
the way are probably the the producers
of the dirtiest oil gas and energy
on the planet Joe Biden think about this
kills the Keystone XL pipeline restricts
all domestic drilling permits blocks oil
exploration on federal lands kills the
Anwar deal all in the name of the
environment but he's now expanding oil
production in Saudi Arabia Venezuela and
probably eventually Iran these are
countries with Dreadful environmental
track records and by the way today our
very own peter Ducey he asked the
question about this very issue take a
look
on the sanctions relief for Venezuela
yeah why is it that President Biden
would rather let U.S companies drill for
oil in Venezuela than here in the U.S
that's not an accurate take on the
president's view earlier this month he
said no more drilling there is no more
drilling does the president think
there's some benefit
not here
not to do with the benefits of the
climate meter
tell me the difference the impact on
Mother Earth if you drill for it here or
drill for it anywhere else anyway he's
about right it's not about the
environment Joe Biden doesn't really
care about climate change he's not the
champion of Human Rights and democracy
claims to be doesn't value high-paying
blue-collar American jobs he's
compromising our national security
abandoning high paying career jobs in
the energy sector he's calling all of us
to pay higher costs to fill our gas
tanks and where do you get your heating
bill this winter it's going to be much
higher than it used to be and this is a
massive cause of our record high
inflation now it's all it all connects
together and sadly nothing means
anything to Biden he really only cares
about politics and like every other
slimy politician he's just kind of lying
his way around life so tonight if you're
really worried about the climate you're
really worried about pollution if you
really care about Mother Earth you might
want to re-examine your support for Joe
Biden because his policies have actually
increased pollution we do a cleaner we
do it faster we do it cheaper for
example drilling uh in for oil in
Venezuela and in the Middle East is far
worse for the climate than producing it
right here at home transporting that oil
and gas on ships and trains is worse for
the environment than pumping it through
the Keystone XL pipeline we'd be getting
900 000 barrels of Canadian Oil a day if
we finished it we could have finished it
over a year ago and signing on to that
ridiculous Paris climate Accord well
that gives China and India a free pass
to pollute pretty much as much as they
want because while we're paying billions
of dollars those countries are
classified as developing nations and
they do absolutely nothing to improve
the environment or our account our
economy and we're bearing the brunt and
we happen to be doing a cleaner than
everybody and as we speak this country
is barreling toward a period of economic
Doom inflation remains at a four decade
High two-thirds of the American people
now living paycheck to paycheck interest
rates continue to climb 401ks are
tanking and now as we've been predicting
home values are beginning their collapse
so are we on the verge of a very very
deep recession with no soft Landing in
sight or is something even maybe worse I
hope not hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else